>> Bret: ALL RIGHT.
>> Will: TAKE CARE, BRET.
I'M WILL CAIN.
AND TONIGHT WE START IN
BALTIMORE, WHICH WAS THE SCENE
OF CNN'S NEWEST HIT SHOW, THE
MYSTERY OF THE MISSING PODIUM.
DESPITE THE EFFORTS OF THE
BRIGHTEST MINDS IN TELEVISION,
THE LIKES OF DON LEMON AND
JEFFREY TUBEN, THE PODIUM WAS
NEVER FOUND.
WHAT IS JOE BIDEN RESTING HIS
HANDS ON.
WHAT IS HE DOING?
IS HE IMITATING THE GREAT CORN
HOLEIO?
IS HE HOLDING TIGHT TO
COHERENCE?
WE WILL NEVER KNOW BECAUSE THEY
DID NOT FIND THE MISSING PODIUM.
INSTEAD CNN AIRED A DISASTROUS
TOWN HALL WITH PRESIDENT BIDEN
LAST NIGHT.
BUT HERE'S THE POINT, WE ARE IN
A SITUATION NOW WHERE IF YOU ARE
IN A CIRCUMSTANCE THAT YOU ARE
NOT ABLE TO PROVIDE -- LET ME
CUT TO THE CHASE -- I'M TAKING
TOO LONG.
>> Will: THAT WAS OUR PRESIDENT.
DOING HIS BEST GRANDPA SIMPSON
IMPRESSION THERE GETTING LOST
HAD N. HIS OWN STORY.
IF YOU LISTENED TO THE LEFT WING
MEDIA, THEY MAKE YOU THINK
BIDEN'S PERFORMANCE WAS ON PAR
WITH A VICTORIOUS GENERAL PATENT
PARADING THROUGH THE STREETS OF
PARIS.
>> I THINK HE SHOWED -- HE WAS
COMMANDING AND YET COMFORTABLE.
THIS IS NOT A PRESIDENCY IN
CRISIS.
THIS DIDN'T LOOK LIKE A GUY
WHOSE POLL NUMBERS HAVE DROPPED.
HE SHOWED WIT.
LAUGHS AT HIMSELF.
I THOUGHT THIS IS A GUY TRULY IN
COMMAND OF THE PRESIDENCY.
>> THIS IS THE WORST MAGIC TRICK
IN HISTORY.
I CAN SEE THE CARD UP YOUR
SLEEVE PAUL BE GALLA, YOUR LIES,
THEY ARE OBVIOUS.
THEY ARE I'M NOT SURE WHAT TOWN
HALL HE WAS WATCHING AIRED ON
THIS NETWORK AND TO BE FAIR TO
BEGALA.
HE PROBABLY DIDN'T WATCH.
NO ONE DID.
CABLE NEWS.
WOULD YOU DESCRIBE THIS ANSWER
AS, QUOTE, COMMANDING 40% OF ALL
PRODUCTS COMING INTO THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA IN THE WEST
COAST GO THROUGH LOS ANGELES
AND -- WHAT AM I DOING HERE?
>> LONG BEACH.
>> LONG BEACH, THANK YOU.
>> Will: WHAT ARE YOU DOING
HERE?
LET ME HELP YOU OUT.
YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO BE RUNNING
COUNTRY AND FIXING A SUPPLY
CHAIN CRISIS OR ANY CRISIS FOR
THAT MATTER.
PICK A CARD, ANY CARD.
PICK A CRISIS, ANY CRISIS.
AS YOU WANDER AROUND THE STAGE.
>> DO YOU HAVE PLANS TO VISIT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> I HAVE BEEN THERE BEFORE AND
I HAVEN'T, I GUESS I SHOULD GO
DOWN THE WHOLE POINT I HAVEN'T
HAD A WHOLE HELL OF A LOT OF
TIME TO GET DOWN.
>> LET ME SEE.
LET'S SEE IF I CAN DIE GRAM THAT
SENTENCE, OKAY?
I HAVE BEEN THERE BEFORE AND I
HAVEN'T BUT I KNOW IT WELL.
IS THAT CONFUSION?
IT'S CERTAINLY A CONTRADICTION.
IS THAT A LIE AND THEN A
CORRECTION SLOWLY BACKING AWAY
FROM THE OBVIOUS LIE JOE BIDEN
NEVER TOURED THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
PRESIDENT, VICE PRESIDENT,
SENATOR AND EVEN A CONCERNED
CITIZEN, HE HAS NEVER VISITED
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
WELL, JEN PSAKI TOLD US TODAY
THAT HE DROVE AROUND IN IN THE
VICINITY THROUGH.
COME ON IS THAT YOUR ANSWER?
DROVE BY IT ONCE.
AND WHILE JOE SPENDS HIS
WEEKENDS IN DELAWARE THERE HAVE
BEEN NEARLY TWO MILLION
APPREHENSIONS ALONG THE SOUTHERN
BORDER AND 2021 ALONE, THAT'S
THE HIGHEST NUMBER EVER REPORT
RECORDED AND, LOOK, WE STILL
HAVE TWO MORE MONTHS TO GO.
YOU ARE RIGHT, JOE.
SHOULD GET ON TOWN THERE AND SEE
WHAT GOING ON A BIDEN FORGETS
THE NAME OF ONE OF AMERICA'S
BIGGEST PORTS AND LIES ABOUT
GOING TO THE SOUTHERN BORDER WE
ARE LED TO ASK WHO IS IN CHARGE
OF THIS WHITE HOUSE?
WHO IS RUNNING THE COUNTRY?
>> DO YOU PRESUME TO CRITICIZE
THE GREAT OZ?
YOU UNGRATEFUL CREATURES THINK
YOURSELVES LUCKY THAT I'M GIVING
YOU AUDIENCE INSTEAD OF 20 YEARS
FROM NOW.
>> OH.
>> THE GREAT OZ HAS SPOKEN.
>> PAY NO ATTENTION TO THAT MAN
BEHIND THE CURTAIN.
>> THIS IS WHAT DEMOCRATS WANT
FOR YOU TO IGNORE WHOEVER IS
PULLING THE STRINGS OF JOE
BIDEN.
WHO IS IT THAT IS BEHIND THE
CURTAIN?
HEY, MAYBE IT'S DR. JILL, JOE
HASN'T BEEN TO THE BORDER BUT
SHE HAS.
>> NOW, MY WIFE JILL HAS BEEN
ON.
SHE HAS BEEN ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE RIVER.
SHE HAS SEEN THE CIRCUMSTANCES
THERE.
SHE HAS LOOKED INTO THOSE
PLACES.
>> Will: SO, JILL BIDEN HAS MORE
BORDER EXPERIENCE THAN OUR
PRESIDENT.
THAT'S A REALLY PROMISING SIGN.
BUT, IF JILL BIDEN IS NOT THE
WIZARD OF OZ, WHO IS.
MAYBE IT'S JOE'S OLD BOSS BARACK
OBAMA WHO IS THE GREAT POWERFUL
OZ.
>> TAX RATE, CORPORATE TAX RATE
35. -- 37%.
BARACK AND I THOUGHT IT SHOULD
COME DOWN, THE PARIS ACCORD,
WHICH WHEN I WAS WITH THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WE HELPED
NEGOTIATE AND THE OBAMA BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
>> JOE SPENDS A LOT OF TIME A
LOT OF TIME TALKING ABOUT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT WHILE NOT
ACTING VERY PRESIDENTIAL
HIMSELF.
MAYBE HE IS NOT THE GREAT AND
POWERFUL OZ.
MAYBE IT'S THE CDC.
MAYBE DR. ANTHONY FAUCI IS THE
MAN BEHIND THE CURTAIN, MORE ON
THAT IN JUST A MOMENT COME UP ON
"FOX NEWS PRIMETIME."
BUT THE SCARIEST ANSWER TO THIS
QUESTION MAY BE THAT NO ONE IS
PULLING THE STRINGS EVERY DAY
THIS WHITE HOUSE LOOKS MORE AND
MORE LIKE A RUDDERLESS SHIP THAT
IS SPINNING AROUND IN CIRCLES,
ALMOST LIKE W